[Applause]
desperate people being pushed back with
water cannon and tear gas
stuck on the belarusian side of the
border polish forces stopping them from
crossing into the eu
it was only a matter of time these
people faced with a lack of food water
shelter and sub-zero temperatures try to
push forward at the crossing at the
brewski
at the front are mainly young men
but many women and children are in the
crowds behind
for those on the receiving end it's an
inhumane and hypocritical rejection by
europe
al jazeera's reporter on the ground
spoke with them
they're using pepper spray and water and
tear gas against the children is this
the human rights of europe ten days
we've been here without water
temperatures are minus five and what can
we do where are the human rights
organizations we were a good country
they invaded iraq in 2003. we've lost
everything we've sold our cars and sold
our houses they've destroyed our country
and now this is their human rights
we haven't slept since yesterday our
feet are freezing and the only word we
can hear is attention attention we have
kids we have wives if they don't want to
allow us through then return us back to
our countries we haven't eaten for five
days only a little food is available for
women and kids we need a safe place we
need a safe country
it certainly is an uneven fight
poland wants to show the world it is
defending europe's border against a
belarusian dictator using desperate
people as a weapon
they say alexander lukashenko is taking
revenge on the eu for sanctions imposed
after his violent crackdown on political
opposition at home
for months belarus has been granting
migrants visas promising them an easy
route into the eu problem
as i have told merkel the problem is
that we don't save those people we would
both lose both belarus and to an even
bigger extent the european union which
didn't let through the refugees to the
eu territory
that's why i proposed on solving the
situation in general we agreed with
merkel that we won't talk about it
specifically she asked for some time for
a pause to discuss the proposal with the
members of the european union that's
fine
as the numbers at the border grow so too
does the desperation they can't go back
poland says they cannot enter that means
we're likely to see more people pushing
forward and the polish forces using
tougher tactics to keep them out assad
beg al-jazeera near the poland belarus
border